[Musica]
si può scoprire di più su una persona in
un'ora di gioco che in un anno di
conversazione quelle che tra noi sono
giocatori sanno quanto sia facile quanto
ci sia capitato spesso
il fatto di rivalutare una persona da
una partita da una singola giocata anche
se magari abbiamo a che fare con quella
persona al di fuori del gioco da anni
ora questo adagio questo pezzo di sapere
che viene dato per antico viene
attribuito a platone
in realtà le prime tracce che abbiamo
sono di uno scritto nel 1670 in cui si
invitano i giovani laureati a fare
attenzione a come una persona reagisce
alla vincita o reagisce alla perdita
allora cosa possiamo capire da come una
persona reagisce alla vincita alla
perdita ma mi spingo ancora oltre
cosa possiamo capire da come una persona
si approccia a prendere quella strada
che lo porterà inesorabilmente e
inevitabilmente a uno di questi due
esiti
io sono stato per una dozzina d'anni un
giocatore di un gioco di carte piuttosto
famoso si chiama magic l'adunanza ho
giocato parecchi tornei con centinaia
con migliaia di persone ho potuto
osservare molti giocatori
essendo né 1 ci sono due cose che mi
piacciono particolarmente di questo
gioco la sua grande profondità
strategica e la possibilità per i
giocatori e biagi e al di fuori delle
meccaniche di gioco
ora come funziona un torneo di magic
funziona su una serie di match in cui
due giocatori si scontrano e vince
quello che per primo vince due partite
su tre
vince il match
la persona che vince due partite su tre
ora immaginate la persona che vince la
prima di queste partite in 12 anni ho
visto persone urlarsi della vittoria a
fare gli spacconi ho visto altre persone
congratularsi con l'avversario
ho visto persone andare in ansia da
prestazione
prima ancora di pescare le carte per la
seconda partita
questi comportamenti hanno un effetto
qualcuno si intimorisce qualcuno si
rilassa qualcuno si rilassa troppo
qualcuno sopravvaluta qualcuno
sottovaluta l'avversario qualcuno parte
già con l'idea che non ce la farà allora
scegliere come comportarsi
ha un impatto immediato sulla partita ha
un effetto immediato su quello che sarà
l'esito della partita
ora la scelta di questo comportamento
all attitudine verso uno di questi
comportamenti ci dice molto di quella
persona ci dice se una persona che tende
ad intimidire a non farsi scrupoli per
intimidire ci dice se una persona che
tende a mettere a suo agio l'avversario
alla ricerca di uno scontro equo ci dice
se una persona che cerca magari di
sfruttare la zona di comfort
dell'avversario per fargli abbassare le
difese
tutto questo non è altro che come quella
persona si interfaccia con l'altro nel
momento in cui ha qualcosa da guadagnare
è una situazione che accade
continuamente nella vita di tutti i
giorni al di fuori del gioco
allora come si pone rispetto
all'avversario come se lo rappresenta
mentalmente come decide anche moralmente
ed eticamente di comportarsi
tutto questo apre una finestra
incredibilmente profonda su chi è
davvero quella persona
badate bene che non ho ancora parlato di
regole meccaniche di gioco dinamiche di
gioco non ho parlato di nulla di tutto
questo
siamo ancora al di fuori del gioco è già
abbiamo incontrato quello che è il primo
ingrediente fondamentale dei giochi che
l'interazione
ora io sono uno studioso della mente
quindi entriamo oppure nei dettagli
entriamo in quello che è il gioco
il mio interesse è capire cosa succede
nella testa delle persone che giocano
allora uno dei giochi che conosciamo
meglio che abbiamo studiato di più come
umanità è il cosiddetto ultimato un game
l'ultimatum game un gioco è ridotto
all'osso per studiare il comportamento
delle persone
funziona più o meno in questo modo vi si
approccia una persona e mi dice mi hanno
dato 100 euro li posso ottenere
solamente se li possa dividere con
un'altra persona
e questa persona accetta la mia offerta
al primo tentativo senza mercanteggiare
altrimenti questi 100 euro il brucia e
procede a farvi un'offerta allora vi
invito a pensare qual è l'offerta minima
che accettereste chi di voi accetterebbe
un'offerta di 20 euro 20 a voi 80 al
offerente chi di voi accetterebbe
un'offerta di 40 40 euro a voi 60
all'altro ok che non si accontenterebbe
di meno della metà chi vorrebbe un una
parte più alta della metà
ora chi di voi si accontenterebbe di un
euro bene ok
la soluzione razionale a questo gioco e
accettare qualsiasi cifra
pensatela in questa maniera
siete stati coinvolti in qualcosa che
non vi aspettavate gli vengono offerti
viene offerta una somma di denaro
e voi ve ne andate con una somma di
danaro in più rispetto a quella che
pensavate di avere che sia un euro che
siano 10 20 40 quello che quello che vi
è stato offerto ora non potendo
mercanteggiare avete solo la possibilità
di accettare o rifiutare perché
rifiutare allora un euro rifiutereste un
caffè gratis probabilmente no è qui che
senso ha che rifiutiamo un caffè gratis
un euro
decenni di studi ci fanno vedere che
metà della delle persone rifiutano anche
somme pari a 25 euro e il motivo per
essere che riteniamo che l'offerta sia
ingiusta
in altre parole stiamo dando un valore
al nostro potere di far ottenere del
denaro all'altra persona
ok questo che il gioco molto molto
semplice da risolvere in teoria ci pone
davanti a una questione interessante le
persone pensano di agire in un certo
modo e si comportano diversamente c'è
qualcosa di fondamentalmente diverso nel
giocare rispetto a ragionare in astratto
le decisioni divengono atti un pensiero
un'idea un piano mentale diventa un
azione e sappiamo ormai che le persone
non agiscono come prevedono di agire che
pensano di adottare dei comportamenti e
poi non li adottano allora questo lo
possiamo vedere facilmente nei giochi di
probabilità e giacche di probabilità non
sono altro che
giochi in cui ci ritroviamo a davanti a
situazioni come decidere se provare a
ottenere ad esempio 10 punti con il 60
per cento di probabilità o 100 punti con
l'uno per cento di probabilità quindi
una somma bassa come una buona
probabilità o una somma alta con infima
probabilità di ottenerlo ok allora
magari sappiamo che ci conviene provare
per la piccola somma sicura piuttosto
che per la grande vincita ma volete
mettere il botto che facciamo se
vinciamo quei 100 punti ecco allora che
siamo davanti al secondo ingrediente
fondamentale dei giochi la strategia
la strategia è quell insieme di scelte
che possiamo fare all'interno di un
gioco c'è un'intera branca dell'economia
comportamentale che guarda caso si
chiama game theory cioè teoria dei
giochi che si occupa proprio delle
decisioni dei giocatori della struttura
decisionale all'interno di un gioco io
da psicologo sono affascinato è
interessato a la nostra rappresentazione
mentale delle opzioni che abbiamo perché
quali sono i fattori che ci rendono più
appetibile la grande vincita il miraggio
della grande vincita assolutamente
improbabile rispetto a qualcosa di molto
più pragmatico molto più possibile da
ottenere come una somma più piccola che
potrebbe permetterci magari di vincere
con sicurezza o con una discreta
sicurezza la partita allora
le persone hanno un piano e poi deviano
su una strada che sembra più
interessante che sembra il seducente
magari più rischiosa no bene allora
intervengono in questi casi quelli che
vengono definiti i buyers cognitivi cioè
delle dei problemi della
rappresentazione mentale ma non solo
intervengono anche a fattori emotivi
emozioni nel ultimatum game
abbiamo il senso di ingiustizia nel
gioco di probabilità
abbiamo l'attrattività seducente di
quella grande vincita ora l'evoluzione
ci ha dotato gli strumenti che non sono
sempre così affidabili non sono sempre
così razionali in un contesto naturale
potremmo trovare utile sovrastimare a
delle basse probabilità ad esempio
potrebbe essere ri conveniente pensare
che abbattere quel mammut sia un po meno
difficile se poi mangio io e mangia la
mia tribù per un mese intero nel
contesto odierno però siamo sommersi di
decisioni continue e spesso molto poco
rilevanti come ad esempio che telefono
comprare sa dove andare a cena stasera
ok è un accumularsi di un errore
sistematico o alla lunga produrre dei
problemi insoddisfazione e frustrazione
ecco che a questo punto il gioco diventa
uno strumento di autoanalisi eccellente
perché questo perché nel gioco noi
modellismo il nostro comportamento
guardando a come noi stessi giochiamo
capiamo quali sono i nostri pattern di
pensiero capiamo come sbagliamo e
capiamo quindi come nella vita reale
facciamo queste cose come nella vita
reale applichiamo schemi fissi
ed errori conseguenti immaginate questa
analisi accompagnata dagli strumenti
della psicologia e delle neuroscienze
cognitive
abbiamo uno strumento potentissimo ora
mancano due ingredienti del gioco che
sono le regole e i premi le regole che
devono essere chiare ed esplicite ci
permettono di descrivere ciò che può
essere fatto e ciò che non può essere
fatto all'interno del gioco
in pratica limitano lo spazio d'azione
dei giocatori invece con i premi noi
stiamo mettendo un obiettivo che i
giocatori cercheranno di raggiungere ora
la combinazione tra limitazione e
obiettivo da raggiungere che è un
ambiente in cui le persone giocano alla
pari
cosa vuol dire giocare alla pari vuol
dire che in un ambiente del genere non
importa più come è andata la tua
giornata
non importa a che piano sta il tuo
ufficio non importa con chi hai litigato
tutto quello che accade nel gioco rimane
nel gioco conta solo l'abilità che il
gioco richiede ora un giocatore per
quanto non competitivo cercherà sempre
di vincere punterà sempre alla vittoria
perché il gioco è fatto così ok allora
la struttura del gioco porta i
partecipanti a cercare di vincere è
legittimo e doveroso per tutti i
partecipanti cercare di farlo non
importa se stiamo giocando con i nostri
figli io col nostro capo ok il gusto del
gioco potrebbe essere proprio questo
cioè giocare alla pari e un sistema di
regole comune in cui conta nient'altro
che l'abilità
il vero motore dei giochi si chiama
motivazione intrinseca è ciò che spinge
a fare un'attività per il piacere di
farla che gioca gioca perché garantisce
il gioco
ok una persona che gioca gioca perché le
piace giocare ma quando gioca ci mette
tutta se stessa
il gioco è costruito su un equilibrio
tra sfida che pone al giocatore e
abilità del giocatore un giocatore bravo
strutture bravo di sudoku non cercherà
sudoku semplice uno scacchista cercherà
avversaria del suo livello
una persona bloccata a un certo livello
un certo punteggio di un videogioco
raggiunto il suo livello attuale di
capacità l'impegno e lo sforzo mentale
sono portati al limite
allora la cosa bella che questo risulta
divertente alle persone
giocarla divertente quindi cosa facciamo
nei giochi
diamo il nostro meglio lo diamo per
nostra stessa volontà e ci divertiamo
ora se noi sapessimo ad una psicologia
del gioco potremo avere accanto alla
game theory una games psycology che
sicuramente non solo di analizzare la
struttura decisionale dei giochi ma
anche di capire come mettere le persone
nella condizione di dare il meglio per
loro stessa volontà e divertendosi
e allora immaginate che possibilità in
mensa abbiamo abbiamo la possibilità di
rendere ogni ambiente della vita un
ambiente in cui le persone danno il
meglio per loro stessa volontà e
divertendo se cioè rendiamo tutto un
gioco
rendiamo l'istruzione di gioco i nostri
figli cresceranno auto motivati ad
imparare saranno curiosi abili di sapere
e andiamo la politica un gioco creiamo
una struttura per cui al governo ci
vadano persone dedite a fare il meglio e
che ci rimangono solo persone che
dimostrano di riuscire a farlo
prendiamola
salute un gioco creeremo un sistema per
cui le persone saranno motivate e si
impegneranno a mangiare meglio ad
adottare comportamenti virtuosi assieme
non sedentarie e andiamo alla conoscenza
un gioco giochiamo
capiamo chi siamo capiamo che abbiamo di
fronte
grazie
[Applauso]